long national nightmare is over we are
happy to report Paul Manafort is behind
bars tonight the 69 year old lobbyist
was shackled and dragged to prison today
on the orders of a federal judge he will
remain behind bars until at least his
trial this fall the president tweeted
about Manafort imprisonment earlier
today quote Wow a tough sentence for
Paul Manafort who's represented Ronald
Reagan Bob Dole and many other top
political people and campaigns didn't
know Manafort was head of the mob
what about Comey and crooked Hillary and
all of the others very unfair that's the
president's view on the other hand with
the dastardly Manafort in a cage the
rest of us can finally relax unchain the
door let the kids play in the yard take
the first deep breath in decades it's a
new day America were safe but
unfortunately do have some bad news to
report as well Paul Manafort score crime
was violating the foreign agents
Registration Act which was passed by
Congress for the first time in 1938 it
turns out that advancing the interests
of a foreign country without first
registering with the US government is an
enforceable felony and that means that
if standards are going to be equally
applied many of the most prominent
people in Washington will soon be headed
to jail Tony Podesta both Clinton's most
of the leadership of Congress in both
parties Jorge Ramos and the entire staff
of Univision all of them take money from
foreign interests all of them advocate
for policies whose main beneficiaries
are foreign countries the law and that
is now clear they are headed to the big
house all of them best of luck Manafort
has also been accused of trying to
influence witnesses in the case against
him that's a very serious charge and
possibly the government will prove it at
trial but as of tonight Paul Manafort
has not been convicted of that or of any
crime in the eyes of the law he is still
innocent and yet somehow he's sitting in
jail now that might be justified if
Manafort were a threat to public safety
or if anyone seriously considered him a
flight risk but he's in late mental age
and has no passport where would he flee
to exactly let's be honest about this
Paul Manafort is in jail tonight because
prosecutors want him to testify against
the president they're sweating him no
rubber hoses or truck batteries but the
point is the same
to put it another way prosecutors want
to influence a potential witness in this
case and as yesterday's IG report show
there's not much know a professional
ethics to restrain them from doing that
obviously